من بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه واحنا
بنسمع بمجموعه ولكن في الايام الاخيره صار
فيه زخم كبير في الاخبار عنهم وصلنا نسمع
باسم المجموعه بشكل اكبر بكثير وان كان
عبر تقارير عنهم او من خلال اخبار بتقدمهم
في او اخبار عن تقدمهم في اوكرانيا او حتى
تصنيف الولايات المتحده لهم كم مجموعه
ارهابيه وكثير من اللي ما لهم في السياسه
والاخبار وكده مو عارفين مين بقدر اصلا
هم شركه عسكريه روسيه مستقله ككيان واداره
وانما التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وتاسست عام 2014 برئاسه يافيدني فرجوان
اللي هو احد الاوليغاركس ومن المقربين جدا
من الرئيس بوتن وحتى انه لقبوا طباخ
وهذه المجموعه بيتم التعاقد معها وبترس
الجنودها الى الدول اللي بتطلب عناصرها
والمعلومات والتقارير بتاكد انهم قاتلوا
في سوريا وافريقيا وحاليا في اوكرانيا
وبيعتقد انه معظم العناصر هم محاربين
قدامى وعناصر سابقه في وحدات النخبه
العسكريه من اللي حصلوا على تدريب جيد وفي
كلام انه الان مع التزايد الحرب واتساع
نشاطهم لجا رئيسها لتجنيد سجناء روس
وعناصر مدنيه روسيه واجنبيه ويعتقد حاليا
انه في 20,000 منهم بيتقاتلوا في اوكرانيا
هم بيدعوا انهم حتى افضل من كتائب الجيش
الروسي وبحققوا انجازات اكثر ومن اسباب
زياده الكلام عنهم اليومين الماضيين غير
التطورات الميدانيه انه في تقرير
استخبارات من الشربي يتكلم عن اساليب
وتكتيك وتفاكن الوحشيه في القتال سواء على
العدو او حتى على افرادها فمثلا بيقول انه
عندهم الانسحاب من المعركه ممنوع واللي
بينسحب يتم اعدامه فورا هذا غير انه
جرحاهم في المعركه مثلا ما يتم اسعافها
وانما بيكمل لا هم القتال وهم شايفينهم
مرميين عادي كده قدامهم هذه غير التعذيب
واساليب القتل اللي همم او باللي
بيمارسوها على اللي بيغلط او بيغرق
قوانينهم التقرير هذا حتى بيقول انه
مجموعه بقنار هي مجموعه لا تكترث اصلا
بموت افرازها واللي عندهم مشكله في هذا
الشيء طيب اوكرانيا موجودين على الخطوط
الاماميه وفيديوهات اون لاين بتظهر القبور
اللي بتنحفر لقتلهم ويقال انه تضاعف سبعه
مرات الشهرين الكلام في هذا التقرير او
غيره من وسائل الاعلام الغربيه المؤخرا عن
المجموعه وحشيه صراحه كثير جدا لكن هل هذا
الكلام حقيقي او هو هل كله صحيح واللي في
جزء من المبالغه من الاعلام الغربي اللي
بيهاجم روسيا ومن مصلحته انه تظهر طبعا
روسيا في اسوا واعنف الصور
خلينا نتعرف اكثر على المجموعه وحقيقتها
من ضيفنا اللي بينضم الينا رياض قهوجي
رئيس مركز الشرق الاوسط والخليج للتحليل
العسكري اهلا فيك معانا يعني القصص اللي
جالسين بنسمعها عن هذه المجموعه الصادمه
جدا فهل فعلا هم وحشين الى هذه الدرجه
ولا يجب ان تفاجئ احد ان هناك مجموعه
قتاليه في حرب همم تقدم على اعماله وحشيه
وبالتالي همم
مؤسسه خاصه
عمل المؤسسات الخاصه التي
تقدم خدمات المرتزقه
للجيوش حول العالم
وتساعدها في
حروبها في فرض امن في مناطق معينه الى
اخره ليس بالامر الجديد همم
بما كانت تملكها امريكا من مجموعات وتر
وهناك مجموعات اخرى في الغرب همم
ناصر مرتزقه همم للخدمه حيث يدفع لهم
وببدا المرتزقه هو عمل موجود منذ سنوات
وفوق في الشرق وفي الغرب
بزياده الموضوع اكثر يعني الحرب دائما
وحشيه وهذا الشيء اكيد يعني والكلام هذا
كله بس كمان في بروتوكولات للجيوش في
بروتوكولات حتى بين افراد الكتيبه هنا
هذه المجموعه كونها ليست جزء من القوات
المسلحه الشرعيه للدوله هي لا تخضع
لقوانين
حتى ان اسراها يمكن للجهه التي تاثرهم ان
لا تعاملهم كسرى حرب لانهم لا يعتبرون
كجزء من قوه الشرعيه لجيش نظامي بل هم
قوات مرتزقه
القوانين الدوليه لا تسري عليهم
حتى الان يعني اوكرانيا
تاثر عناصر من الجيش الاوكراني تقوم
بمعامله اسرى بغنر على انهم اسرع حرب مثل
القوات المسلحه الروسيه وذلك من اجل ان
تبادلهم وتبادل التي يسرونها ايضا يعني
فاتنا اليوم ما يميزها عن الجيش النظامي
الروسي انها تقدم رواتب كبيره اضعاف ما
يقبضه الضابط والجندي في الجيش الروسي
ومنها تستطيع ان تستاثر بنخبه المقاتلين
الروس من القوات الخاصه لانضم اليها
وتقوم ايضا
بتجنيد ال همم السجناء اليوم
ويستخدمون
كدروع بشريه يعني سجناء لا يملكون الخبره
العسكريه معظمهم لا يملكونه العسكريه
وبالتالي يستخدمون اليوم اا في عمليات
كخطوط اماميه همم
تسهل تقدم قوه النخبه
ايه
استاذ رياض يعني الكلام كله اللي بينقال
عن هذه المجموعه وحتى لما انت ذكرت بلاك
ووتر والاشياء دي كلها هذه الاشياء احنا
بنشوفها في الافلام الاجنبيه وبنحس انها
مبالغه انه يصير ويعملوا مجموعه على الجنب
ما هي مذكوره في الحكومه او ما هي في
سجلات الحكومه ومن حسنها كده بس مبالغه من
اجل الافلام الاكشن هذه بس فعلا يعني
الموضوع الموجود حول العالم يعني الحكومات
او الاجهزه الحكوميه بتعمل اجهزه من هذا
النوع
طبعا طبعا هذا الدادا القوات او الاجهزه
الاستخبارات وقوات والاجهزه الدوليه من
قبل
المهام السوداء
وهذه تقوم بها جهات تشتغل خارج المؤسسات
الحكوميه
تقوم بمهام خاصه لصالح جهاد في الحكم ااه
تبقى بعيدا عن مسامع واا امراه الناس
والصحافه
الحكومه بتقول احنا مالنا علاقه فيها دولا
مجتمعنا يعني بيسهل انكارههم يعني طيب
العظمى لديها هكذا مجموعات تقدم خدمات لها
على هذه التوضيحات كان معنا رياض خبير في
شؤون الامن والدفاع شكرا لك